hey guys today i'm going to break down
evidence from the black clover manga
that proves yuna's mother is still alive
and is being kept as a prisoner by the
dark triad
there's one particular panel i found
when rereading the series that confirms
a lot of what i'm about to say because
in the background of it we can see a
member of the spay kingdom royal family
who was there when the magic knights
invaded the castle
as we continue the video i will reveal
where this mystery person appears and by
the end you'll understand how this
theory affects the future of black
clover in a very big way
before we get into it though i'd really
appreciate if you smash that sub button
and drop a like as well if you want to
see more content like this
okay so in the years before the dark
triad took over this bay kingdom we know
that it was the grim barrio family who
were in charge with yuno's parents being
the king and queen for generations their
family possessed a unique brand of magic
related to astronomy with king voice
having sun magic seal having moon magic
and you know having star magic this kind
of magic is so unique that when yuno
finally awakened his power in chapter
309 xenon instantly realized he was
royalty since only a grim burial would
have that type of ability it's important
to remember this going forward because
it means that we can easily identify
members of yuno's bloodline based on
whether they have star magic or other
similar magic types
now moving on i'm going to explain why
the dark triangle left the queen alive
and then after that i'll reveal evidence
proving that other members of the green
burials are also still around
if we flash all the way back to when
king louis ruled the country space
military was known as the major defense
force and all three members of the dart
trial were a part of it
in the black clover anime there was a
scene in which the king was addressing
them and as dante raises his head he
stares directly at yuna's mother and
then just laughed to himself
this scene was never in the manga so
it's interesting that they added a
moment that creates a connection between
queen seal and dante that never
previously existed
what makes this even crazier is that
when he's staring at seal he wasn't even
talking to her he was talking to yuna's
father so it's weird that his eyes would
be focused on the queen when she had
nothing to do with their conversation
this to me was the first hint that dante
had a fascination with seal and it was
further confirmed when the dark triad
took over the kingdom
during the uprising it was dante again
who confronted both the king and queen
but after this encounter the king was
the only one shown to be dead despite
the queen being next to him only seconds
earlier clearly this was meant to imply
that she didn't suffer the same fate and
this is supported by pretty much
everything that happens afterwards as an
example there are at least three times
when someone references the dark triad
attacking the royal family and each time
no one ever references the queen almost
like tabata is trying to avoid
explicitly confirming she's dead
if you're a black clover fan then you
know that if tabata doesn't explicitly
confirm a death then more than likely
that character is still alive i mean
hell even when the death is explicitly
confirmed it can still be undone so
queen seal being alive is more than a
fair assumption on top of that dante's
sinister fascination with her makes
perfect sense when we examine him as a
character
in chapter 244 when he attacked the
black balls hideout he was interested by
grey and vanessa's magic and told both
of them to return back to the spay
kingdom so they could be as women had he
not been defeated then it's guaranteed
he would have taken them by force
because in his mind they didn't have a
choice
this was proven when he initially met
vanessa because after only a few minutes
he declared that she was already his
woman and that she couldn't use her
power for anyone else except him
what this proves is that dante wants to
gather strong women against their will
so that they can use their magic for his
own gain and the anime sets up that seal
was his first victim
as the queen of spades she had powerful
magic that possibly surpassed grey
vanessa and i'd go even as far as to say
that seal might have been arcane stage
because dante seems to be particularly
interested in that type of woman it's
possible that while keeping her as a
prisoner he used her moon magic to learn
more about the underworld as arcane
magic is known to interfere with devils
in various ways
additionally if we consider that dante
is a narcissist who you know refers to
himself in the third person and wears a
crown it's fair to say that he considers
himself to be the king of the spay
kingdom and as the king is only right in
his mind that he has a queen by his side
over the past 17 years still would have
been his unwilling prisoner and by her
being under his control it would make
dante feel more legitimate as ruler of
the country in a second i'll explain how
the rest of the dark tribe would benefit
from queen seal being a prisoner but
first let's talk about the big piece of
evidence i mentioned in the intro which
proves that another member of yuna's
family is around in the present day
during season 4 we got this scene when
the tribe began attacking the castle and
as they killed a ton of soldiers along
the way people began to realize the only
way they'd survive is if they agreed to
submit instead of resisting it's for
that reason that certain members of the
granberry family would have surrendered
and given that xenon value strength
above virtually everything else he would
have definitely allowed a few of them to
join the dark disciples remember
although the royal family magic is
powerful the king was still easily
defeated and yuno admitted his star
magic wasn't strong enough to beat xenon
by itself so the zagato siblings would
have never felt threatened by having
rules among their ranks this finally
brings us to the panel i discovered that
proves this theory to be on any doubt
and the panel in questioning comes in
chapter 275.
in that chapter a select group of magic
knights were transported to the spay
kingdom to defeat the dark triad and
hiding in plain sight is this soldier
who is literally using star magic
this chapter was released 10 months
before union was revealed to have star
magic and as a result none of us knew
how significant it was because at the
time we had no idea what star magic even
looked like
looking back at it now nearly a year
later there can be absolutely no
question that this is the same power and
a member of the grenberrio family is one
of the dark disciples
as you can see from this image they have
at least 10 stars which is double the
amount yuno has but it was revealed in
chapter 310 that the stronger the mage
the more stars they can create
considering that yuno has only had this
power for less than a days of making
this video that explains why he's so far
behind his relative but by the end of
his fight with xenon he was already
making new ones so i feel like he's
going to catch up pretty quickly
while it's impossible for us to know
where this disciple ranks on the grim
burial family tree we can tell from
zooming in that he has light-coloured
hair unlike the king and queen so if i
had to guess i'd say that this is yuno's
cousin but let me know your guesses in
the comments down below whoever this guy
is his existence confirms my theory that
the dark triad are currently using
members of the royal family for their
own gain whether that be as soldiers or
as prisoners
we've already spoken about why dante
would want the queen to be locked up but
for vanica and xenon they'd benefit in a
much different way in vanica's case one
of her greatest powers in the present
day is the ability to control people
with curses as wefina do it to not only
the shining generals of the diamond
kingdom but also to queen lolopecha of
the heart kingdom at some point in the
last 17 years she would have needed to
try out this particular curse for the
first time and there's a good chance in
my mind that she was her first test
subject i say that because in chapter
296 vanika said that when she first
became a devil host she wanted to test
her power on strong people hence why she
went looking to fight noel's mother by
that same logic the queen of spade would
also have been a perfect vessel to try
out curses but unlike asia vanika
wouldn't have been allowed to kill the
queen because she technically belongs to
dante
as a result wherever seal is right now
she's likely under the influence of a
curse that makes her subservient to the
dark triad in the same way le petchka
was
i feel that before the spay kingdom mark
ends yuno will come face to face with
his mother in this condition but with
gordon and astor being a thing i feel
like there's a good chance seal can
still be turned back to normal
now when it comes to how xenon would
have used the former queen i think his
intention wouldn't have been to use her
as a test dummy but rather he wanted to
take advantage of her knowledge
specifically there were the two ancient
demons sealed underneath the kingdom and
each of those demons used to be members
of the grim burial family the royals
were the ones making sure they stayed
sealed all this time but it was xenon
who was eager to release them so maybe
he used sealed for information on where
they were and what magic was needed to
break them free from the ice
presumably there might be other secrets
she told him that we don't know about
yet but overall if this theory is
correct then yunus's mother has been
kept as a prisoner for the past 17 years
and has been used as a test army for
curses been forced to use her moon magic
for dante and has had her royal
knowledge exploited by xenon
following this it's time for us to talk
about how seal being alive solves one of
the biggest problems about the future of
this series
ever since the beginning astri and nunev
had this rivalry to see who would become
the wizard king however one big obstacle
that they'll have to confront eventually
is who's going to rule the spay kingdom
once everything is done although yuno
hasn't shown any desire to be in charge
the fact remains that he is the rightful
heir and members of the spade resistance
like ralph would desperately want him to
take the throne this creates a tricky
situation where yuna will end up
disappointing people no matter what he
does because if he goes back to clover
like nothing happened then the spade
kingdom will have no one to protect them
from the next dark tried level threat
yuno is the only person in spade that
can achieve saint stage so if he was to
abandon his people it means they'll be
less protected if the devils ever
reappear or if there's another crisis
involving devil hosts on the flip side
if he decides to stay then it means the
end of his vow with asta which has been
a major driving force for their actions
in the series so far to break this
promise would be a huge change in
direction from tabata and it would
likely mean that yuno gets less screen
time from now on as he be separated from
all the other main characters this is
where seal comes in as by her being
alive she can solve this problem by
taking back the throne herself
like i said earlier it's entirely
possible her moon magic is arcane stage
so there's a chance that seal is strong
enough to lead the spay kingdom after
this arc is over
even so we do have to acknowledge the
other possibility that after being a
prisoner for 17 years she might suffer
from severe ptsd and in that scenario
she wouldn't have the mental capacity to
be in charge of a whole country
ultimately that means that yuno might
still have to stay behind in spade
because no matter what the nation needs
at least one person in its ranks who can
fight her for devil and if the queen
isn't in the right frame of mind then
surely it's down to her saint stage
having son to take on that
responsibility
this is supported by the fact that
earlier this year on the black clever
website there was a burnt photo of yuno
and astor almost like it's foreshadowing
that their vowel will be broken
interestingly their fist bump is still
intact so what i think this means is
that they will still be friends and
they'll still be rivals but their
promise to become the wizard king has to
end for more important reasons
i mean in astor's case he still can
become the wizard king and he made a
good case for it by destroying the
ancient demon but what i mean is that
their vow their promise to you know go
for it together and try and get this
role see who will come out on top that
would be over anyway guys if you like
this theory then let me know in the
comments do you think seal being alive
makes it more likely or less likely that
yuno stays in spade
as always thank you for watching the
video and be sure to drop a like and
subscribe if you haven't already and
until the next one peace out